when i read these books when in my 20s  about successful people  they all they all owned real estate  all the successful people the the  rockefellers the oil barons the railroad  guys they all ended up with real estate  car dealers car dealers don't make money  selling cars just so you know  car dealers make money  because they pay for their real estate  they rent it back to the store  and they end up with a facility that  pays them forever for for acres and  acres of real estate just so you know  every car dealer in america gets rich  because of their real estate not just  because of their cars the cars pay for  the real estate  how many of you know a rich car dealer  okay mcdonald's ray kroc  he didn't he didn't have the recipe he  got control of mcdonald's because of  real estate  jeff bezos today in every major city in  america right now is making real estate  place